bonjour mesdames Elise Lucet France 2
envoyer spécial vous sortez de faire vos
courses est-ce que vous faites confiance
aux marques vous
êtes l'équivalent de 67 euros de
nourriture par mois en fait
ça correspond à l'inflation quoi alors
il faut qu'on arrête de me casser les
oreilles tous les matins à chaque fois
que j'allume le poste ou la télé à
écouter dire que le lait il est trop
cher la viande foire était d'en manger
les légumes ils sont trop chers nous
l'avons joint par téléphone
[Musique]
j'ai vu des vers de terre
non voilà je me mets là voilà non c'est
mort
[Musique]
original et tout et là j'ai une idée
pourquoi pas mettre mon pentabout comme
Kim Kardashian en plus vraiment je
ressens trop on a le même corps quel est
le premier but déjà parce qu'on a dans
les briques et que bah on a toujours moi
j'ai toujours rêver personnellement de
passer à la télé quoi je traduis ce que
Thibault vient de dire il est là
essentiellement pour pécho et pour le
pognon
avec la perte du contrat qu'il y a
Adidas depuis 2013 hier il a perdu 1,5
milliards de dollars en une journée
combien
1,5 milliards j'ai dit ça fait juste
trois ans de salaire de Killian Mbappé
on s'en fout on s'en fout pas moi
peut-être la fin d'un long feuilleton
entre Twitter et Elon Musk dans une
vidéo publiée hier par ce dernier on
voit le milliardaire faire son entrée au
siège de Twitter avec un lavabo dans les
mains il joue ainsi sur le mot Sync qui
veut dire lavabo en anglais mais qui est
aussi utilisé dans une expression
américaine LED that thinkin traduction
je vous laisse absorber l'information il
y a eu des pellets il y a eu des Zidan
il y a eu des Ronaldo mais tu te rends
compte que c'est bon temps astronomiques
Konaté c'est où la fin en fait à quel
moment ça s'arrête en fait à quel
moments ça s'appelle l'inflation le
football
ça veut pas dire ça signifie pas
cautionner
voilà
nous sommes des hôtes dans un pays
organisateur
comme c'était le cas il y a 4 ans en
Russie il y a 8 ans au Brésil et cette
décision elle a pas été prise il y a il
y a quelques semaines ou quelques mois
on n'est pas sorti du sable
et votre avis justement mais je suis
participant je viens de le dire mais
vous inquiétez pas bien
je suis participant quand je participe
je viens de vous dire participer c'est
pas ça signifie pas cautionner et
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie je
suis gestionnaire RH sur le RER A
gestionnaire RH c'est quoi relation
humaine
amandine est parti c'est
en France on a un gros problème ça
s'appelle les syndicats les syndicats le
conflit entre salarié et employeur c'est
leur fonds de commerce si tu enlèves ça
les mecs ils vont devoir bosser et alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils bossent pas ils sont
payés pour leur employeur à défendre à
défendre
en sorte que des gens qui ne travaillent
ensemble s'affrontent c'est leur fonds
de commerce le fait que les salariés et
les employeurs s'affrontent
43% notre chiffre du jour la hausse du
bénéfice de Total énergie au troisième
trimestre l'entreprise a dégagé 6
milliards et demi d'euros de profit 43%
de plus donc en 2021 grâce notamment à
l'envolée des prix du gaz alors que
l'Europe cherchait à faire des réserves
pour l'hiver dans les salons de coiffure
des dirigeants demandent la coiffure des
entrepreneurs stars en Une des magazines
économiques je cite à chaque fois qu'un
client m'explique la coupe de cheveux il
me montrait une photo de PDG en
couverture du magazine forbs qui les
fascine littéralement depuis je propose
une coupe Ford à un homme d'affaires il
comprend tout de suite les résultats qui
ne devraient pas apaiser la colère des
salariés encore en grève sur les sites
de Gonfreville et de Feyzin plus de 20%
des stations services rencontrent encore
des difficultés d'approvisionnement dans
25 départements et c'est vrai qu'en
regardant les coupes de cheveux des
milliardaires du classement forts je
comprends tout à fait qu'on est en vie
de posséder la même crinière parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils sont forts bien payés
c'est le plus grand et le plus haut
hôtel port-saint au monde qui vient
d'être inauguré un bâtiment aux allures
soviétique 26 étages qui vont accueillir
jusqu'à 650
000 cochons je viens de 650 000 au même
endroit les chiffres sont vertigineux et
quand on regarde les images et bien on
se rend compte à quel point il y a cette
volonté de mettre en avant la modernité
des installations tout est automatisé
les ports sont transportés des tâches en
étage dans des ascenseurs dernier écrit
et ils peuvent même a priori se balader
librement